hi I'm Dana Brower and I'm the director
of the new short film signing out
written by Adriana Leonard and Jenna
Mitch Nell the film is about two women
who still haven't recovered from the end
of their romantic relationship with each
other and they uh nominally find
themselves in the same therapists office
years later and are forced to come to
terms with what happened so I'm here
today to talk to you about the camera
that we use to get the look that we
wanted for this film and we're also in
the midst of an epic crowdfunding
campaign it ends on June 7th 2016 so if
you see something in this video that
tickles you I encourage you to check out
the campaign in the link below so for
the look of this film
Madeline Berger our DP and I talked a
lot about really making sure that the
two segments of the film the past versus
the present president being what's in
the therapy room
past being in the flashbacks we wanted
to make sure that they felt different
but they still felt like they were part
of the same story
so Madeline and I worked on making sure
that the scenes of the therapy office
present day were more sterile clean less
contrast less saturation and when we did
have camera movement it we put it on a
dolly
so the movement was very controlled
whereas the flashbacks the memories when
these girls are remembering the happy
times in their relationship there's a
lot of movement we shot handheld we also
shot Ronin and there was a lot more
saturation higher contrast and just
generally more vibrant so for this
project Madeline and I decided to shoot
red dragon Madeline is an Alexa girl but
unfortunately the budget couldn't afford
Alexa so a lot of the decisions that we
made for this were based on budget that
camera that Madeline and
decided to go with four this was the red
dragon the red dragon compared to other
rads handle skin tones better and it's
also pretty light so it was wide enough
to go on a ronin and they used handheld
without anybody's back breaking the
alarm sensor also allows you to shoot at
a high resolution
and then downsize to reduce noise which
leads me into some of the weaknesses of
shooting red red cameras are noisy oh so
if you shoot at a low ISO lower than
native it actually affects your exposure
curve so it can make the highlights fly
off out of nowhere so to remedy this
madeleine and our awesome awesome camera
team they shot at the skin tones
highlight olp f around 400 ISO which
allowed them to control the highlights a
little bit more and keep them a bit more
contained it's not perfect I know
Madeline has some words to say about
this issue but ultimately it does not
impact I look over film at all and I'm
still very very happy with the look that
we have so in addition to shooting and
the red dragon we actually used ZF prime
lenses for this which was not our
original intention Madeline and I were
really committed to shooting on super
speed as if we could afford it and we
found this sheer grid listing for red
dragon 5 super speed lenses the package
also highly wireless video village lots
of monitors um an easy rig and many
other components that would have been
very expensive to rent independently but
our prep day originally scheduled for a
few days before the shoot had to be
pushed back to the day before the shoot
and when Madeline and the team got there
the super speeds that were advertised
and listening were actually ZF Prime's
so at that point we didn't have the time
or the money to go find something else
that's what we had so the downside to
shooting on these lenses is that ZF
prawns are still lenses and it can
affect the way you pull focus that being
said our first AC Edward Bellamy very
talented guy he was able to make it work
and so is Madeline and the rest of the
camera team but despite it not being
exactly what we want
I'm still very very happy with that look
at the film Madeline is too maybe it
would have been better if we had super
speeds maybe not it's always in
filmmakers head to find this like if I
had this camera maybe it would be better
but this film signing out really is a
testament to the power of independent
filmmaking and the less is more concept
we really were only able to rent exactly
what we needed
so enforced Madeline and her team to
really only use lights and equipment if
we needed it and for this project that
helped us get the look that we wanted
again we wanted it to feel very real we
didn't want to glamorize the flashbacks
or the memories at all we wanted
everything to feel very true and because
we didn't have a lot of lights it feels
that way it doesn't feel like a big
studio production it feels more intimate
so ultimately even though with more
money maybe we would have rented more
lights had an HMI on set the fact that
we didn't have a ton of lights helped us
actually maybe you get closer to the
look that we wanted thank you so much
for watching if anything in this video
connected with you I encourage you to
check out our aceton spark campaign this
is a socially relevant story we were
committed to telling a story about
queerness about an LGBTQ storyline that
wasn't really about that and at the end
signing out is just a love story and we
thought that by portraying an LGBTQ
story in a more mainstream and a more
commercial way we could help change the
conversation about LGBTQ politics away
from other Ness and really help people
to see that love is love and that
relationships are just relationships so
again if that's something that you want
to support check out our students part
campaign